all right and we have to go ahead
everyone it is go time okay oh and
appears to have collapsed
he's simulating having well this is it
folks the big event this evening one man
will attempt to recreate the suicide of
noted pedophile Jeffrey Edward Epstein
it will certainly be a feat like nothing
the world has ever seen and could only
be attempted by the undisputed superstar
of Daredevils Stephen can even Crowder
just even tell the folks at home what
they can expect to see tonight yeah
thanks for audio wait I appreciate you
doing a bang-up job first let me be
clear there about one in a million
details that we cannot go over or
account for in this experiment but let
me be the first to say or let me say
this first on the outset the number that
we are trying to hit on that was a new
Tama tur scale my engineers not here
with me right now it's 55 kilograms 121
pounds of force 55 kilograms 121 pounds
of force is what we're looking to hit to
recreate a scenario in which Jeffrey
Epstein suicide is even plausible
there's even even remotely possible
that's the low-end keep in mind the
story that we've been told as you know
from the New York Times Washington Post
is that Jeffrey Epstein knelt toward the
floor with enough force that he broke
several bones in his neck on a rope that
he fashioned himself from from orange
bedsheets some people thought the
bedsheets were paper that's not true
apparently they were actually real bed
sheets and keep in mind to something
that a lot of people may not know that
when administering death by hanging
the number to ensure death that has
always been used historically is a
thousand to twelve hundred and fifty
foot pounds of force now why aren't you
using that number Steve oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna get to that in just a second and
isn't there something about the hyoid
bone yeah I'm glad that you brought that
up many in the media they've tried to
paint kind of people who are even
remotely skeptical of the epstein
suicide as conspiracy theorists and they
often point to the highway bone claiming
that Jeffrey Epstein fractured that bone
and only requires 35 pounds of force to
fracture and of course that makes it
seem as though it's very easy very
plausible the most likely scenario
that Jeffrey Epstein hung and killed
himself I believe it's a red herring for
several reasons couldn't be less
relevant could couldn't be less relevant
to this for one the measurement being
cited the people often using this was in
a laboratory where they took a hide from
a cadaver and put it into a vise right
that's not the same as a real-world
scenario where you've got cartilage and
tissue and neck fat as I will know then
number two most importantly Jeffrey
Epstein had three fractures in his neck
and you will see us trying to recreate
that here in a second three fractures
including thyroid cartilage which is
much more difficult to fracture than the
hyoid bone so let me kind of paint a
scenario if you get into a car wreck
right you get you get jostled around and
you break your pinkie you break your
wrist but you also break your femur
I can't just recreate a scenario where I
break a pinkie and say well let's go
down for me call it a day we need to
recreate a scenario in which the most
severe fracture is accounted for and
that is what we are trying to do this
evening mimicking the force that will be
required to create all three fat
fractures that were found in the suicide
it's also important to note only 8% of
victims by the way victims of hanging
suicide are found with with broken hyoid
bones keep in mind that these are
suicides by hanging they typically
aren't kneeling right it's usually their
Brooking themselves like in Shawshank
knocking the stool out and hanging from
a beam in the ceiling it's a dead end
familiar it's a great film and by the
way very similar tonight now we're gonna
be crawling through miles of just to
make this happen for you so please use
the promo code and get your $20 off mug
club so this will all be worth that earn
this something else that we need to keep
in mind as well eight percent have a
fractured hyoid bone when you go to the
situation the statistics of people who
have three fractures that we saw in
Jeffrey Epstein suicide that number
drops to one in 20 only one in 20 from
dead hang suicides result in these three
factors and how often is that kind of
fracture found in homicides 34 percent
yeah so one could argue that these kind
of fractures are more likely to occur in
a homicide than in a suicide is that
correct yeah yeah however though when we
discussed this stunt with an engineer as
you well know we've had engineers here
helping with this project wanting to be
as fair mind as possible after reviewing
multiple studies he came to the
conclusion that a real-world scenario
like we've created right here in that
scenario about 121 pounds or 55
kilograms
are what would be required at minimum to
result in the three fractures sustained
by mr. Epstein so we're aiming to
achieve a far lower number than even
necessary to ensure death by hanging
because we want to be as fair-minded as
possible and take the lowest number the
lowest barrier to entry because we don't
know we don't know how any if is gonna
turn out so now before the big stunt
let's go to the tale of the tape the
statement even has a distinct advantage
in both height and weight meaning that
if Epstein wasn't able to produce the
kind of force necessary to kill himself
Steven may in fact be able to we will
certainly see how this affects the
outcome of tonight's event I do want to
say to the number on there is wrong in
the tale of the tape
it's a two ninety now put on some lbs
but happened to the best of us duly
noted please all right so mister can
even is approaching the set we do have a
trained paramedics standing by and again
that number folks that we are shooting
for is 55 kilograms we will be measuring
at the neck as well as the tension of
the rope and it looks like he is being
fitted with a heart monitor getting that
all set to go we have the replica again
of the orange bedsheets that will be
wrapped around mr. can evens neck this
again in line with exactly what the
exactly what mr. Epstein would have
experienced we have the cell here and
the the sheet is about to be placed
around mr. Kuhn evens neck but first his
pupils are being checked there all right
and again we will be measuring for 55
kilograms 55 kilograms we'll be testing
at the neck and on the tension of the
rope all right waiting for the go-ahead
from mr. can even himself all set all
right all right and we have to go ahead
everyone it is go time again 55
kilograms is what we will be looking for
on the road
and at the neck he is leaning we have 22
at the rope we have let's see
28:22 on the roof okay
we're get we're getting the signal to
stop we're getting the signal sorry
something wrong what do we have on the
rope 22 on the Rope the Rope is kilogram
jute we're good
I'm able to cheese okay so one thing I
want to I want to note this is the most
important measurement audio way but this
is probably the least accurate device
that we have so this is designed because
the compression of the neck is going to
be dispersed around the neck the number
is going to be lower than this monitor
right here directly on the cord so
you'll notice that the numbers
significantly lower at the neck
significantly higher at the court the
real Night Live number is probably
between those two but even then leaning
well we got to 22 kilograms okay I'm
gonna try this again and I think I think
that I can actually hold on one second I
think I can actually get this pretty
close in the spirit of being fair-minded
I think I can get this pretty close I
think
okay all right mr. Eddings appears to be
ready waiting for the signal from
alright and we have the signal all set
to go we have with muster can even
believe it again again this is go time
putting his foot against the bed he's
pushing we have 16.1 at the neck 37 at
the neck 38 on the rope 38 on that of 23
as a high on the neck we have and we are
shooting for 55 kilograms we are not
even close 41 is the peak what again
they just stopped 41 on the rope what do
we have on the neck okay
so high it's 23 kilograms on the neck
floor degree on the rope which is the
best that we've had I don't know if you
guys could see how it's pressing up
against the bed of course I probably
have more friction on a plywood panel
here than you would have in a prison we
got pretty close I want to explore every
option here and and do everything I can
to see if we can ever get this number
and I actually I do think that I could
probably
hit this number if if I really push it I
see a little bit of time to catch my
breath that was 44 44 and 22 on the rope
okay 22 on the neck all right so on the
neck that's not even close no not even
what the rope was close the rope was
close
so the real number is probably somewhere
in the 30s yes okay which means you're
still alive all right we have this eight
we have everything the safety mechanisms
that we need to do
Oh - okay good good all right all right
let's get let's get the meter set let me
know when we're good I'm gonna go for
one last try we're ladies and gentleman
is going for one last try we are all set
to go and we have the signal as we are
looking for mr. Connor is rolling mr.
dressed by the again the high on that
was 62 which is far beyond what is
necessary to fracture the neck cartilage
[Music]
mr. Crowder again hell's collapsed he
appears to be okay mr. Crowder appears
to be he is requesting to be checked in
the pupils sixty two point nine on the
rope my goodness we are testing the
limits here mr. Knievel is approaching
now okay hold on audio wait oh look
everyone felt so alive
I have felt more alive but this uh it's
painful huh painful but I don't think I
would suicide it i mister gonna mean
there appears to have been a lot of
commotion over there what do you think
went wrong looks like a please please
okay what were you asking oh I'm gonna
get this off they're gonna take my
helmet thank you
yes there appears to have been a lot of
commotion what what do you think went
wrong um good question I'm still a
little fuzzy I think a better question
is what went right
I seemed like everything kind of went
wrong there the meter was a maladjusted
two pounds initially and that's what we
were getting I thought there was too
much of a discrepancy
we're cut we were kind of expecting it
to be not as heavy on the neck because
of course there wouldn't be as much from
the compression heavier on the cord I
heard those first numbers out there I
panic I thought me we had a calibration
wrong it just turns out that one of them
reset two pounds so that went wrong and
I've had to question some life decisions
that have led me to this point audio way
well mr. can even the viewers have to
know do you believe that Jeffrey Epstein
could have killed himself oh boy that's
a loaded question
well I'll say this if everyone watching
what we really set out to achieve
tonight was to hopefully show you a
real-world scenario where what we've
been told about the Jeffrey Epstein
death doesn't seem to have been entirely
accurate
I certainly even like we didn't even
talk about the hyoid bone but we passed
that really easily could have done that
without the neck brace that's obviously
that's not the number that people should
be concerned about what we set out to
prove was um the people who are
skeptical at all doesn't mean that
you're a crazy conspiracy theorist I
think your criticisms are valid and
we wanted to put on a show hopefully
give you the ability to draw your own
conclusions and give you one hell of a
discount which you know we have offered
tonight with the promo code Epstein at
lateral credit comma slash mug Club and
your your you're signing up tonight
continues to fund episodes like this I
really just buy in time because I've had
to think it through I will say this I
will say this in the spirit of trying to
be fair and as objective as possible if
Jeffrey Epstein had been able to fashion
a rope from bedsheets which takes
approximately 9 to 15 minutes going
completely unnoticed in his cell and if
he were able to achieve the exact right
angle and have somebody wheelbarrow him
in his cell potentially a cell mate and
if you were able to do that and snap his
neck before he passes out as that only
takes you know about 3 to 5 seconds as
we know considering the tension and all
the guards fell asleep I think it is I
think it could be possible it could be
possible if all of those conditions are
met and those conditions would need to
be met I was trying with everything I
had by myself
that wasn't to let that number I do
think that in being objective it is up
it is a possibility as to whether it's
the most likely scenario people will
have to people will have to decide for
themselves well there you have it folks
perhaps will never know what really
happened that fateful night us again be
sure to tweet using the hashtag Epstein
didn't kill himself and go to louder
with Crowder dot-com slash mug club and
enter promo code Epstein for $20 off
thank you for joining us and good night
I say one thing so we don't we did I
love you I love you